IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
FIRSTIES.
INTERNET FOLK LOVE TO BE
FIRST IN THREADS, BUT IT'S
ALWAYS REALLY SAD WHEN THEY'RE
LIKE "FIRST," BUT IT'S LIKE THE
THIRD ONE DOWN.
SO KIND OF LIKE THE WAY I
CAN'T TALK WITH MY OCD UNLESS
I SAY OCD THREE TIMES, OCD.
THAT WAS CLOSE.
COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A
PICTURE OF SOMEONE OR SOMETHING
THAT WAS INTERNET FIRST.
FOR 250 POINTS I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME WHAT THEY FROM FIRST
AT.
ALL RIGHT.
OH, HERE WE GO.
FIRST ONE THIS OLD TIMEY
PHOTO GUY.
THIS OLD TIMEY PHOTO GUY.
>> YOU ARE KILLING IT.
>> WHAT THE [BLEEP] IS WITH
THIS.
>> YOU GOT TO KNOW WHO TO
PAY, MAN.
>> FIRST GUY TO SAY BROWS ON
FLEEK.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THIS IS ACTUALLY
ROBERT CORNELIUS WHO TOOK
THE FIRST SELFIE IN 1839.
THAT IS WHAT THAT IS RIGHT
THERE.
LAST ONE, HOW ABOUT THIS DYNAMO
IN THE SACK.
EDDIE.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST GUY TO
BE EATEN BY HIS OWN CHAIR.
>> Chris: POINTS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THIS IS RAY TOMLINSON WHO
INVENTED [BLEEP] E-MAIL.
>> OH!
THANKS, RAY.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, BONUS, WHAT
WAS THE E-MAIL, TOM.
>> PICTURE OF HIS DICK.
(LAUGHTER)